The Meme Me app let's you create
a meme with an image and some text.
Everyone loves a good meme and it's
a good way to get a laugh from friends.
This is the meme editor.
It let's you select a picture and
edit the text at the top and
bottom of the picture.
The picture can be selected from
the device's photo album, or
the user can bring up the camera.
Whether we're using the camera or
the album, you'll use Apple's UI image
picker controller to select your image.
I like this one of
Jason with James Bond.
Here, text is entered into a text field.
Notice how the view slides up so
that the keyboard doesn't
obscure the bottom text field.
When the editing is complete, we show
the text with an outlined white font.
It's slightly different from the true
meme font, but it's pretty close, and
available among iOS stock fonts.
Now our meme is ready to go,
so let's share it.
Here's our old friend,
the activity view controller, and
I'm going to send this to Kunal.
The app will keep track of
all of the memes you've sent.
You can see the memes in a table view or
a grid.
We can switch back and
forth using these tabs.
Both of these views access
the same meme model objects.
The grid is created using
a UI Collection View Controller.
It's similar to
a UI Table View Controller, but
has a more flexible layout mechanism.
And, from the set memes page,
we can go back and create new memes.